welcome back to CBS mornings and welcome
back to part two of an exclusive joint
investigation with Kaiser health news
into an unproven Dental device it was
offered to cure problems like TMJ and
sleep apnea but some patients say it
left them worse off and some even lost
teeth a dentist in Tennessee invented
the anterior growth guidance Appliance
or AGA for short in his claimed it can
cure Problems by expanding or his word
remodeling the jaw he said it's been
used on more than ten thousand patients
but multiple independent experts tell us
that this device cannot do what he
claims it can our consumer investigative
correspondent Anna Werner found out that
the device has not been reviewed by the
FDA Anna good morning how is that even
possible well Tony that's a great
question and it's one we had too How
could a device like this be out on the
market for years without regulation and
used by patients nearly a dozen of whom
told us they're now suffering the
consequences
meet Nick Hamilton a cyber security
product manager who says he struggled
for decades with jaw problems and pain
my jaw itself would pop a lot a lot of
pain there and my teeth didn't really
line up so like chewing food was very
difficult seeking Solutions in 2019 he
found this Facebook group run by an
organization called the Las Vegas
Institute or lvi which calls itself a
dental learning institution in the group
people with similar problems discuss
their treatment with a Unique Dental
device called an anterior growth
guidance Appliance or AGA it was
invented by Tennessee dentist Dr Steve
gallella seen here in 2017. he's claimed
the AGA can cure problems like TMJ and
sleep apnea by expanding the jaw can you
cure TMJ yes can you cure mild to
moderate sleep apnea yes so Hamilton
selected a dentist from the list on
lvi's website one of many from around
the country who've received AGA training
here at the Las Vegas Institute he said
well dude this is absolutely a case I
can fix this will work for you but after
the installation of the AG device which
looks like a retainer with springs
between Ford and back teeth Hamilton
says he felt intense pain and over time
his front teeth flared out they were
very sensitive I
biting into things was generally
something I tried not to do because it
felt unstable
says he raised his concerns in lvi's
Facebook group but I was removed from
that group so you got kicked out of the
lvi group because you started asking
questions about how this worked yes
lvi's CEO said in court records he'd
removed very few people from the group
but some other patients we spoke to who
were in the group also said airing
problems wasn't tolerated he would
either get
an administrator
like pipe down or don't ask questions
blah blah I mean I got banned from the
LBI group you're not allowed to question
it and you don't understand it and
you're not smart enough to understand it
it was like oh no we're right you know
we're right there there is no other
there is no other way Hamilton finally
decided he had to seek an outside
opinion and got this warning my
orthodontist told me she was horrified
she said do you like I'm scared to death
that you were going to lose up to eight
teeth
up to eight teeth
wow CBS News and khn spoke to five
patients who told us what they read in
the lvi Facebook group convinced them to
get the AGA now they say they have
health problems both lvi and inventor Dr
gallella are now facing lawsuits from
former AGA patients Hamilton is suing Dr
golella in court lvi said when used
properly the AGA procedure Can Be an
Effective course of treatment in adult
patients but as to what studies back up
the use of the device lvi's attorney
told us we're not aware of any
peer-reviewed articles regarding AGA
working and AGA not working there's no
literature to speak to it one way or
another science is science attorney
Scott charnis represents clients suing
over their Agate treatment including
Nick Hamilton and the science will show
that it simply doesn't work and I
challenge them to show that it does but
we found the FDA which regulates Dental
devices doesn't know whether it works
either in fact we found they may not
even have been aware it existed until we
told them I don't see how FJ would know
about this and left this out there Cara
Tenenbaum is a former policy advisor in
the fda's device center based on what
you've seen about the AGA do you believe
that the FDA should be investigating
this device I do and I my guess is that
FDA doesn't know about the device
because no one is reporting the device
to them and she's right CBS News and khn
found no record of the AGA being
registered in fda's medical device
database which the FDA later confirmed
something patience we spoke to didn't
know until after they got it I assume
that in order for a dentist to be
selling it it had to have backing that
it was safe for use but like there was
nothing for this it was just basically
let's just toss this in people's nose
and see what it does there needs to be
regulation 100 I would like to see this
Appliance never be on anyone
's mouths ever
manufacturers are supposed to register
devices with the FDA but in court the AG
as manufacturer said it has no record of
communicating with the FDA about the AGA
before making or selling it and said it
falls into the least risky class of
devices similar to a dental retainer and
is exempt from a pre-market review under
an exemption for dental Labs inventor Dr
gallella said in a court deposition he
believed the AGA was outside the fda's
jurisdiction lvi's attorney told us it's
not subject to FDA regulations but
Tenenbaum disagrees so you don't find
this registered or listed with the FDA
and should it be absolutely who's
protecting the consumer if somebody puts
a device out there
and nobody looks at it and people are
potentially harmed by it that's the
fda's job and I think that there is a
problem here because FDA is not aware of
this device
when we spoke to lvi its attorney said
it no longer teaches classes on the
device and disputed that it had ever
directly taught dentists to use it
however court documents show that AGA
classes were taught for years by lvi's
own co-orthodontic directors now the FDA
wouldn't tell us if it plans to
investigate but they're aware of it now
never a good sign when the the group
that was allegedly educating people on
it says nah never was us never happened
and you had video yesterday showing Dr
guyella talking to dentists at a
symposium talking and of course the
benefits of the event Dr Galileo was
teaching his own classes which are
separate from lvi but the question is
sort of you know now what what happens
at the FDA and so we're kind of waiting
to hear if we're going to get any update
from them on whether they might look
into this just the fact that they
compare it to a dental retainer which I
know a lot of us have worn based on
those gross graphic jacked up teeth that
you showed us yesterday there's no way
that you could even compare it to a
dental to a retainer in my in my opinion
right
the experts what the experts would say
is look if you're making claims that you
can change bone and more and cure
serious diseases and they've galala has
used the word cure then that according
to our experts it puts it into a riskier
category if it's just to hold your teeth
in place that might be a lot less risky
but if you're going to make these kinds
of claims then the FDA is probably going
to say well we need to see some studies
we need to see some proof that this
works we need to see some testing that
kind of thing so a lot of people at home
probably think what I'm thinking which
is if your dentist is offering it surely
the FDA has signed off in some way but
what you're saying is no not in this
case and you've been asking them
questions hopefully they'll respond to
you Anna right I hope the FDA calls you
Mr Warner can we have a little
conversation with you yeah Hannah thank
you we're happy to share information yes
yes really great supporting thank you
Adam